and we're gonna keep seeing churches
deny this act like it's not a problem
but this is a general Trend across the
board women get into spaces you give
them positions of power and Women's
Bible study leadership in the churches
altar girls and they start to change the
culture you cannot give women power we
just are not good with it I don't know
why and this is why I harp so much on
the women shouldn't vote because when we
get power we just kind of ruin things
you can't tell me that's a serious
church service and and what you're going
to see is a lot of super emotional guys
in the church that are Clinging On to a
fantasy that doesn't really you know
exist